and mr. green from bloomberg
businessweek now joins us on our set to
take your calls one of the last things
you said today mr. green on the panel
you were on with Nancy McLain and David
Cay Johnston as a business reporter you
know for a fact that other business
people are going to be running for
president yes are considering it yes
Mark Cuban Oprah Winfrey we've heard
those names who else oh I think you'd
have anybody from Howard Schultz the
chairman Starbucks you know you could
have former athletes you could have you
know entertainers Kanye West although I
have a hard time believing it myself as
someone who's spoken about running for
president in 2020 I think what Trump's
election did in the fact that he was
able to get elected with no political
experience without frankly spending a
lot of his own money convinced a larger
group of people that would ordinarily
consider running for president
especially ones with non-traditional
backgrounds that hey look you know in
this new modern era maybe there's a path
for somebody like me I've got business
savvy or I'm entertainer
I've got name recognition I know how to
communicate with people on television I
think I'm gonna take a plunge in 2020
and see if I can't do what Trump did
what's the devil's bargain that you did
in the title of your book well the story
of devil's bargain is it's the
partnership between Steven and Donald
Trump and how they got elected in the
tight that the bargain in the title is
essentially the bargain that Steve
Bannon struck with Donald Trump Bannon
was the progenitor of a set of ideas
this kind of right-wing populist
nationalism that he believed was
powerful enough to get someone elected
president bannon's first candidate had
been Sarah Palin he tried with Michele
Bachmann the former tea party
congressman he finally met up with
Donald Trump did manage to get Trump
elected the bargain that Bannon had in
mind though was that once these ideas
got elected the president whom he had
essentially elected would in turn
implement them and Trump has only been
willing to do so in a few areas like the
steel tariffs the aluminum terror as we
saw but by and large Trump really hasn't
governed as the
populists he campaigned on he's governed
much more like a traditional Republican
focused on tax cuts for corporation tax
cuts for wealthy people the priorities
of the Republican Party the Trump is a
candidate campaigned against well you
write in your book that he campaigned
against Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell
and now he's governing as a traditional
Republican did Steve Bannon participate
in your book oh yeah absolutely yeah no
I hadn't known I mean I tell the story
in the introduction in devil's bargain
that I met Bannon back in 2011 when no
one had ever heard of him and I was a
political writer for the Atlantic at the
time I just come back from Alaska than a
big profile of Sarah Palin and Bannen
who at the time was a conservative
filmmaker and Palin intimate had called
me up and said hey I read your article
I'd like you to come see my film I'd
like to meet you and the band and I met
in 2011 was no different than the seat
ban and we see today this disheveled
figure and a military filled jacket
brimming with these nationalist ideas
that really didn't have representation
in American politics certainly not in
Republican politics back in 2011 but
have since become the force that's given
rise not just to the Tea Party but to
Donald Trump
the Mercer family are they still with
Donald Trump I think the Mercer family
are still with Donner Trump I have a
chapter about the Mercer's in devil's
bargain and essentially they were the
merchant bankers who funded Steve
bannon's various projects these
nonprofit foundations the book Clinton
cash which was instrumental in tearing
down Hillary Clinton helping Trump to
get elected they're very much behind
Trump as I'm sure you know the Mercer's
Trump and Steve Bannon have had a
falling out you know Bannon after the
publication of Michael Wolf's book was
kind of cast out of Republican circles
out of Trump circles Trump himself
attacked him went to the Mercer's and
said essentially you need to choose him
or me they chose Donald Trump so the
Mercer family is still very much on
board with Donald Trump and his politics
Bannon though still aligned I think with
Trump's politics is no longer a part of
that equation at least for now
I'm sure you saw that Rebecca Mercer
about a month or so ago had an op-ed in
the Wall Street Journal basically saying
everything you've read about me don't
believe this is what I stand for and it
was pretty traditional Republican
principles yeah it was and I think part
of part of what Mercer was reacting
against was things written by
journalists and authors like myself and
the book which showed some of the
radical political candidates that the
mercer's has supported some of the
radical ideas you've had other
journalists like Jane Mayer at The New
Yorker Zachery mitre who I work with at
Bloomberg who have illuminated some of
the very unusual far right and even
cranked candidates that the Mercer's
have supported but on the other hand
they've managed to be very effective
you know they funded and built up the
institutional infrastructure I think ban
and to is key in this effort whether it
was the Government Accountability
Institute a Florida think-tank that
helped produce the Clinton cash book
whether it was Breitbart news that was
such a platform for you know pro Trump
journalists and voices and propaganda
during the political campaign or whether
it was Cambridge analytical the data
science firm that that was embedded with
the Trump campaign and helped him win
the election all of these things were
Mercer vac projects and I think had a
profound effect on the election and on
Trump's ability to win well let's hear
what our callers have to say Betty's in
Roanoke Virginia Betty you're on book TV
with author Josh green hi Josh I have a
question for you I saw I think it was in
the New York Times that Steve Bannon was
in Europe I believe it was this weekend
working with marine lepen giving
speeches and what you would call
nationalist I really see as like he's
just drumming up the haves against the
have-nots and using a racist based
platform in order to excite people I'm
one I'd like to get your comment about
is that a surprise to you that he's in
Europe too if it isn't
how do you see that having an effect
both in Europe in terms of the spread of
like a liberal democracies and also its
impact on the United States particularly
in the run-up to 2020
thank you it's a it's a great question
and Bannon has always been fascinated by
populist nationalists fascists in Europe
you know I tell the story of the lineage
of some of his political ideas in
devil's bargain and Bannon read all the
fascist philosophers of the 1930s and
the 1940s people like Julius Avila who
was kind of a Mussolini's brain for a
while he studied Soviet propaganda
filmmakers Leni Riefenstahl the Nazi
filmmaker really I think Bannon wanted
to absorb how it was that they were able
to shape public ideas and manipulate
public sentiment he's always had a
fascination with Europe before he came
to Trump when he was the head of
Breitbart news he opened up a Breitbart
news Rome to report on the Vatican he
had plans to do the same thing in
Germany Germany Italy and France didn't
manage to do that but but he believes
that Trump's election was part of a
global right-wing nationalist uprising
that had swept across Europe it had
swept through Great Britain and
manifested itself and brexit and the
Trump selection was not necessarily due
to anything Trump had to say himself but
rather the Trump was was the vessel of
the Venice beneficiary of these energies
I talked to Bennett while he's in the
White House last spring during the
French French elections and one of his
great frustrations was that because he
was in the White House he was not able
to go over to France and help marine
lepen in her election against the Manuel
macaron Bandon thought that had he been
able to do that she might have won so
it's really no surprise to me that now
that Bannon is at least for the time
being through with American politics
that he's moved over to Europe to back a
lot of these right-wing in some cases
racist and anti-semitic parties that
seem to be on the rise I think it's what
it's his way of continuing to be
involved with it with this movement that
I think Bannon believes still has
strength in the United States even if it
temporarily went into decline after
Trump was elected Barbies in Newark New
Jersey hi Barbie please go ahead
hi yes I'm concerned that Social
Security is privatized no security will
be treated by pension managers and
financiers and corporate CEOs and
bankers and said we will take advantage
and take advantage advances and bonuses
as and see just like oil corporations
like especially insurance companies news
media corporations to take their
subscribers and subscriptions and
project them into the future as evidence
they are going to continue into the
future they will alright I think we got
the point Barbie Thank You Josh Green
privatizing Social Security well you
know it's been a long-term goal of a lot
of the more libertarian thinkers on the
right George W Bush made a push to do
that after his re-election it failed I
don't I don't see this becoming a danger
in the short term you know politicians
seem to have learned Republican
politicians that Social Security is the
third rail of American politics and that
if you touch it if you make this effort
to privatize Social Security
voters who depend on it like the caller
will react by going out and electing
different leaders we've seen a variation
of this I think in Trump in the
Republican Party's efforts to repeal
Obamacare the Affordable Care Act
it caused a counter movement that caused
that push to fail so I think that while
it remains a goal of certain people in
the Republican Party so long as photos
who rely on Social Security
you know organize come out to town hall
meetings put pressure on the
representatives not to cut it that the
program will remain intact
who's got president Trump's here today
well the answer that question is whoever
happens to be the guest that morning on
Fox and Friends which seems to be the
main conduit of Trump's interest there's
a direct correlation between what
they're talking about and there is
literally a direct correlation between
the people they're talking about and not
only that but in speaking to interest
groups around Washington DC
people who look to influence Trump are
now starting to buy ads
during Fox & Friends this was true of
some of the steel companies that were
pushing for the tariffs that Trump
enacted they knew that the way to reach
him was to advertise on these shows and
you know in the case of the steel
companies that got the result they
wanted to so you know it's not clear
always who Trump is listening to people
tend to come in and out of favor and
Trump's even in Trump's own White House
you know for a while in the fall when
tax reform is on the agenda he was
listening to Gary Cohn his outgoing
director of the National Economic
Council very Wall Street friendly pro
corporate traditional Republican Cohn
himself in fact the Democrat was pushing
traditional Republican ideas more
recently however he's pivoted to the
nationalist camp and listened to
nationalist trade advisers like Peter
Navarro who had been pushing these steel
and aluminum tariffs since the outset of
trumps presidency
well Martin's in Potomac Maryland and
Martin you're on with Josh green yes
Thank You Josh I disagree with you about
everything you say I think you suffer
from the belief that politicians are
more honest than businessmen I say
there's no different at one in both
camps I'd like to say some other things
I think that their mode of it well do
you have a question sorry Martin you go
ahead and finish up and then we'll let
Josh respond if you believe that social
security isn't a Ponzi scheme can you
explain why there is no social security
the money has been used ever since
Johnson was elected all right I don't
understand the question or what the
caller's okay we'll just let him make
his point and we'll talk to Zachary and
pardon me Long Beach California hi
Zachary you're on the air Thank You mr.
green for taking the call my question is
do you think that the president will
continue to support them after those
policies nobody says that's what happens
like them thank you so I had a little
trouble here with a base support him
over what I had the same trouble and I
was hoping that you caught what Zachary
was saying and I didn't but there's I
think I got an idea that he was talking
about president Trump's base may be a
little poor not as wealthy as the
Democratic base and yeah and I mean one
of the this came up on our on our book
panel earlier here at the Book Festival
was you know Trump ran on a certain set
of ideas it seemed to be very
blue-collar focused you know one of the
things that differentiated Trump from
the other Republican candidates was the
devout not to cut programs like Social
Security like Medicare like Medicaid in
fact in the effort to repeal the
Affordable Care Act he did do so and yet
you know by and large most of trumps
base has stuck with him not all of them
there have certainly been defectors his
approval rating has fallen among certain
Republicans who voted for him especially
independents who voted for him but by
and large I think Trump has managed to
maintain his base because you know he
really is the non-traditional divisive
figure he ran is somebody's gonna come
up in shake up Washington norms not
comport to ordinary traditional
standards of presidential behavior and I
think Trump has also been very good at
stoking cultural battles that keep his
base loyal to him whether it's over you
know issues like you know steel tariffs
and Chinese take advantage of us and
trade deals this Trump would claim or
whether it's issues like Colin
Kaepernick the NFL quarterback who
started this trend of taking a knee in
response to police brutality that's
something that Trump is mentioned again
and again and again and it's something
that clearly resonates with his voters
and keeps them loyal to him even if he
isn't delivering on many of the kinds of
policies he promised that would help
these you know downscale rural white
voters who were the core of his base
Josh green given that you met and knew
Steve Bannon since 2011 you've been
following this and you cover
business did November 8 2016 surprise
you know it really it really did and I
and I sort of make a confession in the
preface to my book that you know having
been embedded with Bannen for years
having spent the last three years of my
life as a reporter covering the
emergence of the populist right if
anyone should have been able to see this
victory coming it would be me and yet I
didn't I didn't realize until about 9:00
p.m. on election night that Donald Trump
was gonna be the next president and I
think that's partly because you know I I
was captive to the same set of
assumptions and essentially you know
working within a bubble that said people
like Donald Trump really can't get
elected you know in the end either his
voters aren't going to materialize or
Democrats even those who might like some
of what Trump has to say and don't like
Hillary Clinton will come home and vote
for in the end you know it's my surprise
along with just about everybody else's
Trump was able to win a Magette role an
electoral college victory you know and I
think that's on me as a reporter and
part of the story of devil's bargain
essentially is for people like me or
frankly my mom who called up the next
morning and said what on earth happened
you guys in the media all told me that
Hillary was gonna win part of what I'm
trying to do in this book is go back to
the very beginning with hindsight and
tell the story of exactly how this
happened and yet people who should have
known better like me weren't able to see
it in real time Jim and Cranford New
Jersey good afternoon yes hi I don't
have a question but I want to make two
very quick comments the first comment is
to introduce the second comment now hang
up and listen I wanted to thank you for
your demeanor on the last panel you were
a lone voice of reason and composure
because you shared the stage with a
hooligan and a harridan and I chose
those words to make a point I heard from
that stage the word libertarian linked
with words of racist fascist and KKK and
that tactic is precisely what you're
criticizing the right for dilling I'll
hang up and listen to your comments
thank you sure you know I approach these
issues as a journalist objectively I'm
not looking to push a certain agenda I'm
looking to you know analyze and explain
what happened
in the election that's why I think one
of the appeals of devil's bargain my
book is that I'm not carrying water for
one side or the other and when I appear
on the panels to talk about politics
whether it's the book or current events
you know I try and do it through an
analytical lens and not a partisan lens
and I'm glad that that appeals to
viewers out there watching on TV so
thanks for the comments I appreciate it
in the conclusion of your book quote
every president changes the contours of
American politics and Trump will - oh
absolutely there is no question that
Trump is changing the contours of
American politics already both in the
norms that he's breaking and how he
behaves and comports himself but I think
more fundamentally he has broadened the
possibilities for what sorts of people
could run for president and how they
should run for president we talked
earlier in the show about the
possibility that people who who might
not have been thought of as serious
candidates in the past prominent
business leaders prominent retainers
like Oprah Winfrey could now give
serious thought to winning a party
nomination as they should because Trump
showed how it's done I think he's also
showed that American voters in both
parties I think Bernie Sanders also
helped show this our longing for you
know less decorum and more authenticity
in their candidates you know if you talk
to Hillary Clinton staffers and people
around her one of the things that they
regret in hindsight was that she was you
know very risk-averse is is a very you
know composed and an emotive candidate
traditional in that sense and was up
against someone in Donald Trump who was
able to capture the media's attention to
keep public attention riveted on him
both by people who support him and by
people who didn't you know I think
Bernie Sanders had some of that same
energy so I think going forward if you
want to be a successful politician at
the national level in presidential
campaigns you're gonna need to
distinguish yourself by a kind of
authenticity that we now realize is more
important in the wake of Donald Trump
Loren and Sparta Wisconsin we have 30
seconds left alone do you think Barack
Obama might be legally couple of
for interfering in Israeli elections
supported that now you not use a point
and also you think David Broughton will
ever run for president I don't need you
who's gonna run for president I don't
think Obama had anything to do with
Russian collusion and that's why Robert
Muller is looking at Donald Trump and
Republicans instead of Democrats like
Hillary Clinton so we'll wait and see
but I wouldn't expect proof to be
forthcoming that former President Obama
was colluding with the Russians although
I realized there are right-wing outlets
that suggest otherwise bloomberg
businessweek senior national
correspondent political analyst on CNN
former senior editor of the Atlantic and
author of this book devil's bargain
Steve Bannon Donald Trump and the
storming of the presidency updated and
out in paperback last month Josh green
thanks for being on